احييكم مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
لسفينه التي وصلت الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده والتي تحمل رعايه العديد
من الدول فضلا طبعا عن مواطنين السعوديين
هذه السفينه هي سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع
تحمل على متنها العديد من
المواطنين كان من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه المملكه المتحده السويد ايطاليا
قطر سوريا هولندا العراق تركيا تنزانيا
لبنان وليبيا اذا تم نقلهم من خلال سفينه
جلاله الملك ينبع حيث طبعا حرصت المملكه
على توفير كامل الاحتياجات الاساسيه
للرعايه الاجانب تمهيدا طبعا لتسهيل
مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
وبذلك مشاهدينا يكون وصل اجمالي من تم
اجلائهم من السودان منذ بدء عمليات
الاجلاء طبعا منذ ايام نحو 356 شخصا بينهم
101 من المواطنين طبعا السعوديين
و255 شخصا ينتمون لست وعشرين جنسيات اذا
مازلنا نراقب وصول هذه السفينه وطبعا
زميلنا سلطان متواجد هناك نامل ان يستطيع
ان يعطينا تفاصيل اوفى سلطان اذهب اليك
الان لتطلعنا على مشاهداتك الان من خلال
وصول هذه السفينه الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده
نعم اهلا بك اهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه بالفعل حتى هذه اللحظه كما نشاهد
الان عمليات استعداد نزول الرعايه على
الرعايه الذين هم على متن سفينه جلاله
الملك ينبع عشره دقائق فقط تفصلنا عن
عمليات عن تجهيز عمليات الانزال سوف يكون
في استقبالهم قناصل بلدانهم وهم من 14
جنسية نتحدث على 199 شخص من 14 جنسيه
والحصه الاكبر هم للجاليه الليبيه نتحدث
على 104 شخص نتحدث على عشره السعوديين هم
على متن هذه
هذه السفينه وبذلك نتحدث النون تنسيقات
وجهود كبيره فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء
من الخرطوم الى بورد سودان برا ومن ثم
وصولا بحرا الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده كما اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه نتحدث
الاكثر من 350 شخص تم اجلائهم نتحدث على
100 وواحد
اكثر من 66
اكثر من 26 جنسيه مختلفه على متن هذه
السفينه فقط 14 جنسيه ولا تزال عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره من الخرطوم وصول الى بورت
سودان ومن ثم الى
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هنا في جده
نتحدث انه حتى هذه اللحظه
356 شخص من ضمنهم 101 سعودي نتحدث على 255
شخص من 26 جنسيه مختلفه على متن هذه
السفينه العملاق الضخمه اعذرني على
المقاطعه ولكن دعنا نتابع ايضا هذا الخبر
العاجل الوارد الان من الخارجيه المصريه
حيث تؤكد الخارجيه المصريه مقتل مساعد
الملحق الاداري المصري في سفارتها في
الخرطوم اذا الخارجيه المصريه تؤكد مقتل
مساعد الملحق الاداره المصري بسفارتها في
الخرطوم بعد ان كان هناك
كان هناك الحديث عن ملحق عسكري في السفاره
المصريه وكان الجيش السوداني اعلن هذا
الامر ومن ثم نفى هذا الامر
الجانب المصري اما الان الخارجيه المصريه
تؤكد مقتل مساعد الملحق الاداري المصري
بسفارتها في الخرطوم وليس الملحق العسكري
كما تم ذكره في السابق اعود اليك سلطان
الاليه التي سيتم تسليم فيها الان هؤلاء
الرعايه من يستقبلهم كيف يعني هل سيبقون
في السعوديه
ما هو الوقت الذين سيتبقون في السعوديه
قبل الانتقال الى بلدانهم هل لدينا اي
تفاصيل عن اليه
الوصول الى بلدانهم
في البدايه حرصت الحكومه السعوديه على
تقديم كافه الخدمات اللوجستيه والطبيه
والاعاشيه لهؤلاء الرعايه فور وصولهم الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هنا في جده اذا
تحدثنا عن حال الرعايه الذي وصلوا خلال
يومين الماضيه تم انهاء اجراءات سفرهم
لدخولهم المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومن ثم
تمنع تم نقلهم عبر حافلات خاصه الى مقرات
السكن وفرتها الحكومه السعوديه عباره عن
اربعه فنادق ضخمه وكبيره جدا في جده لاخذ
قسط من الراحه والتاكد من صحتهم وسلامتهم
وتلبيه كافه احتياجاتهم ومن ثم سوف يتم
التعامل مع انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر
الخاصه بهم ومن ثم يستطيعون حينها الذهاب
الى بلدانهم في حال جوزيتهم او في حال
كذلك رغبتهم ليس هنالك وقت محدد فرضته
والحكومه السعوديه عليهم يعني بكل تاكيد
يعني اعطتهم المهله حتى ياخذون قسطا حتى
ياخذون راحتهم في الاستقرار ويستقرون بشكل
جيد نتحدث عن حاله ماسويه عاشوها في داخل
الخرطوم وصول الى بورت السودان معاناه
كبيره عاشها هؤلاء الرعايه بمختلف جنسيتهم
لذلك هنالك تعامل خاص وتعامل مرن من قبل
الحكومه السعوديه لهؤلاء الرعايه التي
كمرحله الاولى يتم نزولهم من هذه من السفن
ومن ثم يتم استقبالهم من قبل الجهات
المختصه الاناء اجراءات سفر ودخوله انهاء
اجراءات الدخول المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومن ثم يتم بعد ذلك نقلهم عبر حافلات خاصه
الى مقرات السكلتها الحكومه السعوديه
بوجود عدد كبير من القناصل وعائلاتهم
والقيادات الامنيه العسكريه المتواجده
للتاكد من سلامه عمليات التنسيق وعمليات
الاجلاء والتاكد حتى الى عمليه وصولهم الى
مقرات سكنهم وتلبيه كافه الاحتياجات
الخاصه بهم هذا هو الحال الذي يعيشه كافه
الرعايه بمختلف جنسيتهما تحدث عن اكثر من
سته وعشرين جنسيه اكثر من 300 اكثر من 255
بشخص اجنبي دخل الى السعوديه عبر عمليات
الاجلاء الخاصه التي قامت بها الحكومه
السعوديه بتنسيق مع كافه الاطراف في
السودان لضمان عمليه السودان
على لسان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه حيث
يقول هناك اتفاق بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع على وقف اطلاق النار ويبدا
منتصف الليله
ولمده ثلاثه ايام سيكون هذا الاتفاق او
هذه الهدنه اذا على لسان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه يقول الاتفاق بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع على وقف اطلاق
النار ويبدا منتصف الليله وحسب المعلومات
التي وصلتنا بان هذه الهدنه ستكون لمده
ثلاثه ايام اذن حسب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على لسان وزير خارجيتها ستبدا
هدنه جديده منتصف هذه الليله بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع على كل حال طبعا
نبقى اعيننا على
تفاصيل هذه
الهدنه وهذا الاتفاق بلنكن يقول بان
الهدنه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
ستسري على جميع انحاء البلاد اذا ايضا
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول بان هذه
الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم السريع ستجري على
جميع انحاء البلاد نامل ان تصلنا تفاصيل
اكثر حول هذا الاتفاق ومدى الالتزام بهذه
الهدنه اذا هدنه بين الجيش السوداني ودعم
السريع لمده 72 ساعه وستبدا منتصف الليله
اذا هذه اخبار ايجابيه للسودان بعد كل هذا
الاشتباك المسلح وهناك عده هدنات حقيقه
حصلت خلال هذا الاسبوع ولكن الاشتباكات
كانت ما زالت متقطعه من حين الى اخر لم
يكن هناك التزام لهذه الهدن طبعا نامل هذه
الهدنه ان تكون انت
ويستطيع
السودانيون ايضا ان يتنفسوا بعد هذه
الايام التسعه الحقيقه يعني كانت صعبه جدا
على الشعب السوداني من خلال هذا الاشتباك
المسلح بين الجيش
والدعم السريع اعود اليك الان السلطان نحن
طبعا بانتظار الرعايه الاجانب وايضا
السعوديين الذين وصلوا على متن هذه
السفينه سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع على قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه ما زلنا بانتظار
نزولهم سلطان صحيح هل بداوا بالنزول ام
بعد
بالفعل يعني قبل قبل الخوض في التفاصيل في
حال تطبيق هذه الهدنه سوف يعني سوف يسهل
بشكل كبير في عمليه تنقل الرعايه من
الخرطوم الى بورت سودان او حتى الى
المنافذ الخاصه بالسودان وصول الى بلدانهم
سوف تسهل بشكل كبير وسوف تزداد الاعداد
بشكل اكبر فيما يتعلق بعمليه النقل نعلم
انه عمليات التنقل بين الخرطوم والمحافظات
الاخرى لعمليات الاجلاء هي صعبه ومحفوفه
بالمخاطر بشكل كبير جدا في ظل الوضع
الماساه الذي يعيشه المجتمع تعيشها
السودان بشكل عام والاشتباكات المسلحه
التي لا تهدى خلال الايام الماضيه الان
يتم تجهيز السلم الخاص بنزول هؤلاء
الرعايه كما يظهر امامكم قوات السعوديه
مسلحه هي تعمل على تامين هؤلاء الرعايه من
السودان وصولا الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه هنا بجده قوات مدربه ومؤهله
للتعامل مع كافه الحالات التي الفتره لا
سمح الله اثناء عمليات التنقل من الخرطوم
الوصول الى بورتسودان ومن ثم بحرا الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه من متوقع بعد في
حاله ما نادي الهدنه والعمل عليها من قبل
الطرفين المتوقع ان تزداد هذه الاعداد
بشكل كبير وكما نوهنا في وقت سابق للحكومه
السعوديه لا تزال تعمل فيما يتعلق بعمليات
الجلاء وهي عمليات مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
من المتوقع وصول السفن اخرى يوم غد كما
انوه السفير السعودي في الخرطوم بانه سوف
ان عمليات الاجلاء الخاصه بالقوات
السعوديه هي مستمره ومتوقع ان تصل يوم غد
ايضا السفن بحريه اخرى على متنها رعايه من
مختلف الجنسيات اليوم الحكومه السعوديه
تتعامل مع كافه الطلبات الخاصه بالاجلاء
وتقوم بدراستها وقبول البعض منها بما
يتناسب ونشاهد كما ذكرنا قبل قليل تنوع
كبير الجنسيات نتحدث على الجنسيه الدول
الاوروبيه ومن امريكا ومن بريطانيا ومن
دول خليجيه وعربيه وكذلك حتى دول الاسيويه
لنشاهد انه في خلال السفن الاربعه الماضيه
وهي كانت العمليه الاولى فيما يتعلق
بعمليات الاجلاء البحريه شاهدنا جنسيات
مختلفه من قطر والامارات والكويت
وبنغلاديش والسودان ومصر وفلسطين ومن
السعوديه وغيرها من الجنسيات التي قامت
بعمليات اجلائهم الحكومه السعوديه
بالتنسيق مع حكوماتهم وكافه الاطراف هنالك
لضمان سلامه وصولهم بحرا الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مع تقديم كافه التسهيلات
وفيما يتعلق بالاجراءات الدخول وكذلك
عمليات
السكن وايضا فيما يتعلق بالتاكد من
سلامتهم وصحتهم وتقديم كافه الرعايه لهم
حتى يتمكنوا من مغادره بلدانهم في اقرب
وقت ممكن بعد تسجيل مهمتهم مهمه وصولهم
الى السعوديه فيما يتعلق بالقناصر
والاهالي التقينا في بهم قبل قليل هم
ينتظرون بكل حراره وبكل شوق نزول رعاياهم
لاستقبالهم وتطمن والاطمئنان عليهم بشكل
كبير التقينا بالقنصل الامريكي الذي وجه
شكره للقياده السعوديه وكذلك التقينا بها
القنصل الليبي في جده وايضا وجه الشكر
واكد انه على ثلاثه التعامل وسهوله
التنسيق بين الحكومه الليبيه والحكومه
السعوديه وكذلك ايضا التقينا بالسفينه
التركي الذي ايضا اكد على ثلاثه التنسيق
وسلاسه عمليات نقل الرعايه من الخرطوم
وصول الى بورت سودان ومن ثم الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه ايضا هذه السفينه على
متنها قوات بحريه وكذلك قوات خاصه مدربه
لتامين هؤلاء الرعايه والتاكد من سلامتهم
حتى يصلوا الى ارض الوطن هنا في جده ومن
ثم بعد ذلك يتم استقباله من قبل سفراتهم
وقناصلهم لانهاء جراءاتهم حتى يتسنى لهم
الى بلدانهم في اقرب وقت ممكن بعد انهاء
كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه بذلك خدمات كبرى
تقدمها كافه القطاعات
الامنيه العامه للجوازات والجمارك وقطاعات
صحيه وامنيه يتواجدون بشكل مكثف خلال
اليومين الماضيه وحتى هذه اللحظه داخل
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده للتاكد من
ثلاثه عمليات الاجلاء والتاكد منه تلبيه
كافه طلبات واحتياجات هؤلاء الرعايه من
خلال وجود مترجمين من خلال وجود مسعفين من
خلال وجود اخصائيين اجتماعيين التعامل مع
الحالات النفسيه الصعبه التي قد تتسم على
وجيه بعض الرعايه بعد المعاناه التي
عاشوها داخل السودان في ظل الفوضى الكبيره
والعارمه التي يعيشها المجتمع السوداني
وكافه الرعايه هناك فيما يتعلق باعداد
السعوديين وصلت حتى هذه اللحظه الى مئه
وواحد مواطن السعودي وصلوا حتى هذه اللحظه
نؤكد انه هم كافه الرعايه السعوديين وصلوا
الى ارض المملكه من المتوقع ان تختلف
الجنسيات وتزداد اعدادها من 26 الى 30
جنسيه خلال يوم غدا بعد وصول السفن الخاصه
بعمليات الاجلاء من بورسودان وصولا الى كم
من الوقت اخذت هذه الرحله السودان الى جده
فيما يتعلق بعمليه التنقل بره من الخرطوم
الى بورسودان هي مسافه تصل الى 850 كيلو
متر اين نتحدث الاكثر من ثمانيه الساعات
ومن ثم بحرا من بورسودان وصول الى
السعوديه ما بين عشر ساعات الى 12 ساعه
حسب الحاله الجويه
لاثناء الرحله
يعني طبعا نحن نتمنى ايضا عندما ينزل
الرعايه الذين وصلوا الان الى جده الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه على سفينه جلاله
الملك ينبع نتمنى ان يتسنى لنا الحديث
معهم ليعطونا شهادات عن هذه الرحله حقيقه
بالمصاعب بالمخاطر بعد ان عاشوا تقريبا
تسعه ايام قاسيه جدا في السودان وساعات
طويله من السفر من الخرطوم الى بورت سودان
وامبورتسودان للوصول الى جده
سنعود ونذكر مشاهدينا بانه هذه السفينه
التي وصلت تضم السعوديين كما قال زميلنا
سلطان
وايضا
الكثير من الجنسيات اكثر من 24 حتى تصل من
الممكن ان تصل الى 30 جنسيه ايضا كان
القنصل اللي بان هذه السفينه تحمل على متن
تشاهدوننا العائلات والقناصل نعم نعم
نشاهد الان وجود العائلات وبعض القناصل
والسفراء لاستقبال رعاياهم نتحدث عن 14
جنسيه متواجده على متن هذه السفينه كما
ترصد امامكم كاميرا العربيه هذه اللقطات
الحصريه والخاصه لهؤلاء العائلات والرعاء
والقناصل والمسؤولين في السفارات الاجنبيه
لاستقبال رعاياهم والاطمئنان عليهم اريد
ان اخذ لقاء الان نعم يعني اذا كان هناك
من امكانيه لقاء ومن ثم اعود واسالك عن
الاوضاع الصحيه وكيف يتم
اذا كان هناك من تواجد ايضا لاي حاله صحيه
اذا كان هناك من تواجد لمنظمات هي التي
تهتم بامورهم الصحيه اليك سلطان
نعم نؤكد انه الحكومه السعوديه ممثله
بكافه قطاعاتها الامنيه والصحيه هي
متواجده للتعامل مع كافه الحالات الصحيه
ان وجدت ان كان هنالك اصابات او جروح
لهؤلاء الرعايه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه ليس
هنالك اصابات او جرحه على متن كافه السفن
البحريه التي قامت باجلاء الرعايه من خلال
يومين الماضيه وحتى هذه اللحظه من السودان
بدايه ان نتعرف عليك
مياه هادي نائب القنصل العراقي في جده
اليوم علامه السفينه جلاله الملك ينبع
نشاهد رعايه عراقيين كيف تمت عمليه
التنسيق بين الحكومه السعوديه والحكومه
العراقيه لقد تمت عمليه التنسيق على اعلى
المستويات وكانت رده فعل سريعا ومباشره
جدا من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهذه المبادره الانسانيه التي اطلقها خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك محمد سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ولعهده الامين محمد الامير محمد بن
سلمان وهذا هو هذا ما عودتنا عليه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه من رده فعل
انسانيه شملت كل كل الجنسيات ليست لم
تقتصر على دوله عربيه انما شملت كافه
الجنسيات وهذا ما نراه الان الان بام
اعيننا نرى ان كل جنسيات موجوده على هذا
المرفق وهذا الميناء لاستقبال رعاياها
وهذا ما عودتنا عليه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه بانها صاحبه المبادرات
الانسانيه واغلى ما يكون هو انقاذ النفس
البشريه والانسان وهذا ما رايناه الان
شكرا للمملكه العربيه السعوديه حكومه
وشعبا شكرا لكم
عفوا كيف سوف يتم التعامل مع الرعايه
العراقيه طبعا اكيد احنا هناك امور
بالتعاون مع وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه امور
اللوجستيه منظمه ان شاء الله سيتم اخلائهم
من هنا ومن ثم ترتيب عودتهم الى العراق
وان شاء الله ان شاء الله يرجعون سالمين
امنين الى الديار وكل الجنسيات العربيه
شكرا لك كما نشاهد هنا الجانب العراقي
وايضا جنسيات مختلفه وقناصل يتواجدون
لاستقبال رعاياهم فور نزولهم من هذه
السفينه ايضا نتحدث عن اجراءات كبرى يتم
العمل عليها من قبل الحكومه السعوديه
وكذلك
الجهات المعنيه الموجوده بمختلف اشكالها
نتحدث عن وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وكافه
القناه
الاجنبيه في السعوديه لاستقبال رعاياهم لا
لا شيء هنا يطغى سوى على سوى مشاعر الفرح
التي تتسم على وجوه الرعايه وعلى وجوه
اهاليهم وكذلك القناصر التي تتواجدون
حاليا من 14 دوله مختلفه ايضا الان سوف
ناخذكم او سوف نحاول الوصول الى داخل او
اخذكم معنا في جوله خاصه وحصريه الى داخل
سفينه جلاله الملك
ينبع لنشاهد معكم الاعداد الكبيره
للرعايه واختلاف الجنسياتهم لنشاهدهم
ونتاكد من سلامتهم وكذلك وصولهم ونزولهم
بشكل كبير جدا ايضا نتحدث عن عمليات اجلاء
مستمره كما نوهنا في وقت سابق الان لحظات
محدوده وبسيطه جدا سوف يقومون بالنزول عبر
هذا السلم الذي تم وضعه الان وهو بهذا
الشكل وبهذا التصميم لسلامه نزولهم بشكل
كبير جدا ايضا يتواجد القوات البحريه وعدد
من الموظفين المدنيين
لاستقبالهم والتاكد من سلامتهم ونزولهم
بشكل كبير جدا ايضا نتحدث عن انه العدد
شخص سوف يقومون القوات البحريه السعوديه
بعمليات انزالهم بشكل سلس وكبير جدا ايضا
لحظات هي محدوده تم الانتهاء من تركيب
السلم الخاص بعمليات النزول والان سوف
ننقل معكم الصوره الحيه
والمباشره صوره الحيه والمباشره لعمليات
النقل الان سوف ننتقل معكم كما تشاهدون
الان
الان نشاهد الان الان الان نعم
الان سوف نظهر معكم الان سوف نقوم بالدخول
وصولا الى العربيه الان لحظات بسيطه وسوف
نقوم بعمليه الدخول الى علامه السفينه
جلاله الملك ينبع وصولا الى الرعايه
والالتقاء بهم والتاكد من سلامتهم وصحتهم
بشكل مباشر معكم الان نعم الان نستقل معكم
هذا السلم وصولا لقطات خاصه لي وحصريه
للعربيه كاول كاميرا تصل على متن او تصل
الى متن متن سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع
لنشاهد معكم هذه اللقطات الحصريه بعد
ثواني مع دوده لنشاهد الرعايه ونشاهد كيف
هي صحتهم وكيف تمت عمليات الاجلاء والنقل
لهم من بورت سودان وصولا الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه
لحظات بسيطه الان سوف نصل شكرا لكم ولذلك
تسهيلات كبيره من قبل
التسهيلات كبيره من قبل القوات البحريه
لدخولنا على هذه السفينه مشكورين الان
نشاهد القوات الخاصه المسؤوله عن تامين
عمليات
وصول هؤلاء الرعايه بكل يسر وسلاما نشاهد
تجهيزات كبيره جدا من قبلهم
نشاهد الان
لقطات حيه ومباشره للرعايه على يسار
الكاميرا كما نشاهد الان هؤلاء بجنسيتهم
طبعا الاطفال
وكبار سن وعائلات يتم استقبالهم بالاعلام
السعوديه وبالحلوه
يتقطع سلطان ولكن ما زلنا نحن مع هذه
الصوره يعني على الرغم من تقطعها ولكن ما
زلنا نتابع معك هذه الصوره
ساتركك الى حد ما ان تصل بين الرعايه
الذين وصلوا الان علامات سفينه جلاله
الملك ينبع الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
نعود ونذكر مشاهدينا بانه هناك يعني
العديد من الجنسيات الذين وصلوا على متن
هذه السفينه وايضا كان هناك
واضحه الان الصوره واضحه سلطان نعم
الان الصوره واضحه
نتعرف عليك اسمك ايه
وانت اسمك ايه
وين يا رفيده من فلسطين اهلا وسهلا هؤلاء
العائله هي من فلسطين كما تشاهدون كيف تمت
عمليه اجلائكم الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
من شو اسمه من الخرطوم لبورسودان ومن
بورسودان شو اسمه
اول شيء نشكر الملك العربي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لانه كان شو اسمه كثير
كثير كويسين معنا والحمد لله كانت معامله
احسن من هيك ما في شكرا اله كما تشاهدونها
امامكم بعض مشاعر الفرح ممكن نلتقي ببعض
العائلات الموجوده معنا اليوم ممكن نتعرف
عليك
انا احلام من سوريا احلام من سوريا كيف
تمت عمليه جلائك يا احلام الى من الخرطوم
الى بورسودان الى جده تم الاتفاق مع
السفاره اللبنانيه والسفيره اللبنانيه
عملت اتصالاتها مع السعوديه مشكورين كتير
على كل شيء قدمتوه من جهدك نحن بنشكركم
كثير من قلبنا
في الخرطوم الخرطوم ما في
قصف عشوائي يعني على اولادنا وعلى حالنا
انه تشتد الاشتباكات بيناتهم عرفت كيف
حرام حرام السودان يكون صار فيها هيك حرام
ولا ابني وبنتي وجوزي الحمد لله على
السلامه نورتوا السعوديه كما تشاهدون
جنسيات مختلفه ومشاعر مختلفه ايضا نستضيف
معنا احدى الاشخاص الموجود يتعرف عليك
محمد مالك من سوريا ونعم محمد انت ايش
طبيعه عملك في السودان انا رحت اناقش
رساله ماجستير ولكن اشعه الظروف عن يعني
ما ناقشها فتاجلت فان شاء الله يا رب الله
يعيد الامن والامان ان شاء الله للسودان
وان شاء الله نرد مره ثانيه وان شاء الله
انت ما تنساها في الخرطوم وش اللي اختلف
معك بعد ما وصلت قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده
اذا ما زالت الصوره تتقطع نحن بانتظار
وصلنا لقاعده
يوم وصلنا للقاعده منك بالسعوديه الحمد
لله يعني ما قصروا السفير كان موجود
والملحق العسكري كان موجود والحمد لله
كانت الامور وايد زينه شكرا لك لا اعلم هل
الصوره لازال تتقطع ام واضحه صوت وصوره
لذيذ الان جيده
[موسيقى]
نعم نشاهد الان الاطفال هم يحملون الاعلام
السعوديه وكما تشاهدون مشاعر الفرح
والطمانينه والامان تتسم على وجه هؤلاء
الاطفال الذين عاشوا بطبيعه الحال ظروف
مختلفه وصعبه جدا ممكن نلتقي بهذا الشخص
نتعرف عليك
السلام عليكم بسم الله انور بن شعبان
مستشار بالسفاره الليبيه الخرطوم اليوم
104 شخص ليبيا على متن هذه السفينه ما هي
عملك في السودان وعدد اطفالك وكيف تمت
عمليه النقل ولما وصلت قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه ايش اول شيء يعني جاء في بالك
حاليا اول شيء هو الشكر الجزيل للقياده
والشعب السعودي على الجهود اللي بدلت في
سبيل اجلال رعايه الليبيين 104 شخص طبعا
طلقنا من يوم الخميس صباحا الى يوم الجمعه
رحله طويله لمده 25 ساعه الى مدينه
بورسودان وبعد ذلك بقينا ثلاثه ايام حتى
تمت عمليه
الجلاع بوصول السفينه ينبع
نقدملهم كامل الشكر الطاقم وكابتن السفينه
على الجهود اللي بدلوها في سبيل راحت
ومساعده جميع الرعايه الليبيين شخص يمثلون
طاقم السفاره بالكامل
وموظفين ومداراه شركات يعملون بالسودان
والشكر الجزيل هؤلاء بناتك نتعرف عليكم
في السودان
ما كنت حاسه
[موسيقى]
في السودان
بعد ما طلعت على سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع
اختلف معاك الوضع اللي تحت كثير
مشاعر اطفال طبيعه الحال يعني وعفويه
كبيره من قبلهم الان نشاهد قائد الاسطول
الغربي يصل ليتاكد من سلامه كافه الرعايه
في هذه في هذه الان كبير هذا المقعد او
كبير السن
ثم سمو سيدي ولي العهد الامين هم اللي
امروا الشيء هذا انت في ارض الامن والامان
انت في مملكه الانسانيه اللي ما ابدا لن
يعني تتوانى بتقديم العون لاي شخص يحتاج
هذا السعوديه هذا ولا تامرنا الحمد لله
الله يعطيك العافيه الله يعطيك العافيه
كما نشاهد مشاعر مختلفه وقيادات امنيه
كبيره على متن هذه السفينه للتاكد من
تلبيه وسلامه كافه احتياجات هؤلاء الرعايه
بمختلف جنسياتهم كما نشاهد الان هذا الرجل
المقعد الكبير السن تقدم له كافه الخدمات
له
يا رب العالمين
هذا السعودية ما عمره تاخرت باي شيء الا
اتمته على اعلى درجه من العمل والاحترافيه
والامن والامان انت في ارض الامن والامان
في ارض الحرمين
المره الثانيه انا عامل عمليه في خروجتي
في رمضان الماضيه في مكه ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه هذه بعض المشاهد
واللقطات
الالتقاطات واللقاءات مع بعض الرعايه من
قبل المسؤولين الحكومين السعوديين كما
نشاهد الجميع هنا ليتاكد مطمئن على سلامه
الرعايه بمختلف جنسياتهم واعمارهم ايضا
نشاهد كذلك اعداد كبيره على مجلس السفينه
يستعدون
بحقائبهم للنزول العلاقه ان نزول في قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه
خلال لحظات بعد استقبالهم بالورود
والاعلام والحلوى ايضا كما نشاهد مراحل
عمريه مختلفه واطفال
وكذلك فيما يتعلق في حال وجود العائلات
والاطفال في مناطق الصراع او مناطق الحروب
هي بطبيعه الحال تسبب ازمه كبيره لذويهم
ولعائلاتهم ولكن نشاهد البسمه اليوم ترسم
على اوجه الاطفال قبل كبار لبعد وصول الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده وتحديدا
بعد وصولهم الى السعوديه وسوف لحظه بعد
لحظات قليله سوف يقومون سوف تقوم القوات
البحريه بانزال
الاطفال والعائلات
لانهاء اجراءاتهم ومن ثم للتاكد من انهاء
اجراءاتهم واصالهم الى مقرات السكن لاخذ
قسط المره ايضا لفت نظري ممكن نتعرف ممكن
نعرف شو اللي موجود
ايش اللي موجود في الصندوق
تم اجلائها معكم
كنا بالخرطوم
وطلعنا على بورسودان
وطلعنا على الفندق عند السفير السعودي
وقدم لنا كل الشغلات الكويسه وكان معنا
يعني
بكل شيء خير يعني وقدم كل الشغلات
المستلزمات اللي احنا عايزينه
ومشى لنا امورنا وبنشكر الملك سلمان
وابنه ومحمد ولي العهد شكرا لك يعني كما
ارشادتم الان في على الكاميرا مباشره حتى
فيما يتعلق بالحيوانات الاليفه الخاصه
بالرعايه يتم كذلك
اجلائها عبر سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع اليوم
نؤكد ونعيد التاكيد انه الحكومه السعوديه
ممثله بوزاره الخارجيه والسفاره السعوديه
في الخرطوم وكذلك القوات البحريه السعوديه
تعمل على تلبيه كافه احتياجات الرعايه
والتسهيل لهم اثناء عمليات نقلهم والتاكد
من تلبيه احتياجاتهم
وسلامتهم ايضا نشاهد الان مشاعر
يعيش فرحه كبيره وفرحه مختلفه بعد وصولهم
الى بر الامان بطبيعه الحال
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع وصول الرعايه
الاجانب وايضا بعض السعوديين على سفينه
جلاله الملك ينبع في قاعده ملك فيصل
البحريه
وطبعا العديد من الجنسيات على متن هذه
السفينه تم تقديم كل التسهيلات
لهؤلاء الرعايه حتى يصلوا بامان الى جده
ومن ثم يتم نقلهم
والى بلدانهم هناك العديد من الدبلوماسيين
والقناصل والمسؤولين من كافه الدول التي
تصل رعاياها على هذه السفينه متواجده هناك
من اجل استقبالهم وايضا انهاء كل الامور
التي يحتاجونها وكانت طبعا الخارجيه
السعوديه
تحدثت عن وصول هذه السفينه الى ج
وقالت بانه هناك عشره مواطنين سعوديين على
متنها وبلغ عدد رعايه الدول طبعا الشقيقه
والصديقه التي تم اجلائهم نحو 189 شخصا
الجنسيات المتواجده على متن هذه السفينه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المملكه
المتحده السويد ايطاليا قطر
هولندا العراق تركيا تنزانيا لبنان وليبيا
وطبعا تم نقلهم عبر هذه السفينه دعونا
نذهب الى سلطان
نعم انا يعني اشاهدك يعني دموع على خديك
يعني لماذا هذه الدموع
وهلا جينا هون وحاسين بامان اول شيء بفكر
فيه
احبابنا اصحاب من كلهم انه يحسوا نفس
الاحساس
الحمد لله الحمد لله نشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه على كل قدموا لنا طلعونا وجابونه
وقعدونا الطريق كنس وما قصروا معنا بشيء
ما في خدمه طلبناها ما كانوا موفرين
فالحمد لله اكيد هذه الدموع خرجت بعد
معاناه كبيره عشتها في الخرطوم طبعا اكيد
اكيد تعبنا كتير تعبنا كتير لطلعنا وبس
الحمد لله يعني الواحد ربنا معه ويسر لنا
الطريق وهنا زي ما قلت لك ابدا ما قصروا
معنا يعني رحلتنا ممكن لما
باي تعب يعني كله خلص كان راح الحمد لله
شكرا لك شكرا يعني كما نشاهد بلقطات حيه
ومباشره نعيد نؤكد ان هنالك علاماتنا هذه
السفينه
199 شخص من 14 جنسيه مختلفه من ضمنهم
عشره السعوديين تنوع كبير في الجنسيات
والرعايه واعمار مختلفه جدا كما نشاهد
امامكم ومشاعر مختلطه بالفرح والخوف
والامان بعد ان عاشوا اوقات الصعبه واليمه
في الخرطوم بشكل كبير خلال الايام الماضيه
لذلك نشاهد هذه المشاعر وكما نشاهد حتى
الاطفال اليوم باعمار مختلفه اليوم من
الاولاد والبنات الصغار باعمال مختلفه بس
نتعرف عليك لو سمحتي
[موسيقى]
لبنان كم عمر البنت واسمها
يمكن انت كام
شبيهه باوضاع السودان قد تشعرين بقلق
مختلف وكبير جدا
السعوديين ما شاء الله عنهم رسونا للخوف
نسونا القلق اللي كنا فيه ما شاء الله
الله يحميهم شعبا ودوره وحكومه
ايش طبيعه عملك وسبب وجودك في الخرطوم
وكيف كنتي عشتي لحظاته والايام الاشتباكات
المسلحه والله كانت لحظات كتير
ولا اكل ولا نوم ولا شرب زوجي شغال هناك
صار له يعني اكثر من 15 سنه بيبقى صناعي
يعني عشنا كتير ايام صعبه بس الحمزه الله
فرجها وجينا لهون الحمد لله
يعني نحاول نلتقي بالمزيد من الرعايه
ونتنوع في الجنسيات ونحاول ان نعرف او
نكتشف مشاعرهم واحاسيسهم المختلفه التي
واللحظات الصعبه والقاسيه التي عاشوها في
الخرطوم خلال الايام الماضيه اثناء عمليات
اجلائهم ايضا نؤكد على سهوله عمليات
الاجلاء من الخرطوم
برا ومن ثم بحرا الى
قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالاطفال هنالك يعني
تعامل خاص من قبل
ومهيا لهم وكذلك توفير الاطعمه والمشروبات
وكذلك حتى
المشتقات الحليب حتى يستطيع الاطفال حتى
يتم تامين الحليب ومشتقات
الصغار سنا تحديدا
اعلان اعذروني على مقاطع كما نشاهد احدى
العسكريات التابعات لقوات البحريه
السعوديه الان تحمل هذه الطفل او الطفله
وهو اعتقد انه
يشعر
بالارهاق او بالتعب او النوم وها هي
والدته الان بجانبي موجوده كما نشاهد يعني
خدمات انسانيه يعملون عليها القوات
البحريه
رجالا ونساء كخدمات انسانيه تعمل عليها
القوات البحريه قبل الخدمات الامنيه
والعسكريه للتسهيل على كافه الرعايه
بمختلف جنسياتهم ايضا نتحدث عن انه دقائق
محدوده بسيطه في ظرف
ومن هنالك حافلات خاصه سوف تقوم بنقلهم
الى مقرات السكنهم فورا بعد انهاء
الاجراءات الخاصه
بهم الاعداد كبيره كما نشاهد الان
يستطيعون يعني كما تشاهد امامكم الان
مشاعر مختلفه اعداد كبيره لحظات محدوده
وسوف يتم انزالهم وانهاء اجراءات سفرهم
نتحد نؤكد من عددهم مئه وتسعه وتسعين شخص
الحس الاكبر من الرعايهم لمواطنين
الليبيين بعدد 104 وكذلك من ضمن الاعداد
او علامتنا هذه السفينه عشره السعوديين
واكثر من 14 جنسيه مختلفه
طبعا تابعنا مع زميلنا سلطان السلمي او
وصول سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه كما ذكر السلطان بانه
هناك عشره سعوديين علامات هذه السفينه
هناك
اربع عشره جنسيه متواجده على هذه السفينه
حيث تم تقديم كل التسهيلات
اللوجستيه وايضا كل ما يلزم لهم
منذ وصولهم الى بورسودان حتى
وصولهم الى جده كانت الرحله طبعا تم
اهتمام بشكل كبير بكل هذه الرعايه وايضا
القناصل
والمسؤولين متواجدين في هذه القاعده
لاستقبال
رعاياهم وطبعا لتسهيل امور سفرهم الى
بلدانهم اذا هذه السفينه التي رست بجده
تضم
189 من 12 جنسيه وعليها ايضا عشره
السعوديين هذه السفينه هي الخامسه تقريبا
التي تصل الى جده الى السعوديه
وهذه عمليه الاجلاء منذ بدايتها كان هناك
اعمال جباره
لانهاء الاجلاء بطريقه سلسه ولوصول
الرعايه الى جده ومن ثم الى بلدانهم
والان مشاهدينا دعونا نذكر قبل ان نعود
الى موضوع السودان طائره فلاي دبي التي
شهدت حريق بمحرك جراء اصطدام بطائر خلال
اقلاعها من نيبال هبطت بسلام اذا طائره
فلاي دبي التي شهدت حريقا بمحركها جراء
اصطدام بطائر خلال اقلاعها من نيبال هبطت
بسلام هذه الطائره طبعا التي يعني انطلقت
تقريبا منذ اربع ساعات وكان هناك حادث
او اصطدام بطائر الان هبطت بسلام الان
سنعود ونذكر بالاخبار العاجله الوارده من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وطبعا الخاصه
بالسودان حيث اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن اتفاق الجيش
السوداني مع قوات الدعم السريع على هدنه
لثلاثه ايام تبدا منتصف الليله ايضا قوات
الدعم السريع اعلنت من جانبها الموافقه
على هذه الهدنه اذا هناك هدنه لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه تحدث عنها وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انتوني بلينكن والدعم السريع
وافق على هذه الهدنه ينضم اليه الان من
الحدود السودانيه الاثيوبيه عمار الضوء
الصحفي المهتم بالشؤون الافريقيه عمار
اهلا بك معنا كيف يمكن هل يمكن ان نعول
على هذه الهدنه لانها تقريبا هي الثالثه
هل من الممكن ان يكون هناك التزام وخاصه
من اعلن عنها الان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
عمار هل انت معي
نعم الزملاء داخل الفيديو لكم التحيه من
الشريط الحدودي ولايه القضارف الشرق
السودان هذه الهدنه هي تعتبر الثالثه من
نوعها بعد اندلاع الحرب منذ عشره ايام
ونيف يمكن لهذه الهدنه ان تساعد كثيرا في
عمليه الاجلاء واخلاء الجرحى والمصابين
والشهداء حيث بدات عمليات الاخلاق
عبر عدد من المعابر الحدوديه معلوم ان
حدود السودان تمتد مع عشاء عشره دول من
الجوار من اكبر المعابر التي تم تمت بها
عمليه الاجها هي المعبر الحدودي الذي نحن
الان بجواري هو معبر القضارف القلابات وهي
حدود تمتد مع الجار اثيوبيا لولايه
القضارف بطول 265 كيلو متر بدات عمليات
الاخلاق
الماضي ويبقى ترتيبات تمت عبر حكومه ولايه
الجمارك والاجهزه الامنيه بعد ان تم تامين
الشريط الحدودي عمليه الاخلاء يعني كانت
تسير هو ما هو مخطط له وتركيب حيث تم
اخلاء نحو الحين من عده دول منهم دوله
الصومال وجيبوتي وبريطانيا وامريكا وتركيا
وجنوب افريقيا وايضا هنالك عدد من
السودانيين قادروا عن نسبه لارتفاع وتيره
الاحداث وارتفاع الضحايا وارتفاع حالات
المصابين ايضا هنالك عدد من الطلاب
بالجامعات السودانيه منهم طلاب من دوله
الصومال وطلاب من جيبوتي وطلاب من جنوب
افريقيا وطلاب من ملاوي وطلاب من ليبيريا
عمار كيف يتم التنسيق بعمليه الاجلاء على
هذه الحدود
عمليه الاله هذه تمت بحضور عدد من السفراء
منهم سفير جيبوتي وسفير موزمبير وكثير
اثيوبيا الذي اعلن عن نقل اعمال سفاره
الاثيوبيه من ولايه القضارف معلومه هنالك
قنصليه كانت من قبل تقوم بعمليه التاشيرات
ويبغى التعامل كامل مع سلطات حكومه راتب
عبر الاجهزه الامنيه المختصه في الجوازات
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه
ايضا نعلق على هذه الصوره نزول اول شخص من
الرعايه على متن هذه السفينه وكنا تابعنا
طبعا القوات البحريه كيف ساعدته واوصلته
الى هذه البقعه من حول السفينه لا ادري
اذا سلطان اصبح جاهزا معي تفضل سلطان
نعم انني نعم انت يا عم اول شخص يصل الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده قادمه من
السودان نعم مرحبتين
يعني مهما اتكلم ومهما احاول اعبر عن
شعوري وتقديري لخادم الحرمين الشريفين
لولي عهده الله اعطال في عمرهم اللي قدموه
ليله شعوب عربيه
ولا حتى دولنا
لانه فعلا الناس يهتموا بالانسانيه
ويطببوا الدين الاسلامي عليها صحيح والحمد
والشكر دعوه ابينا ابراهيم
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى انه يوفق الملك
ولي العهد
السعودي بما فيه خير البلاد والعباد انت
كشخص يعني
ظروفك الصحيه كيف تم التعامل معك مع
مراعاه ظروفك الصح
والله صدقني
مما وصلت
بورسوداك
والعساكر
ما خلوني دقيقه واحده
اي حاجه انا كنت في حاجه لها القها قدامين
من غير ما اتكلم فيها وهنا انا
سالوني على كتوفهم طلعوهم اكثر من مره
دخلوني في غرفه شهداء سرير عنه ما اقدرش
يعني الخدمات اللي قدمت بالنسبه لي ومتاكد
انها انا وبس ودي كل من نحتاج لها في هذه
البلاد من الضيوف
كامله
ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى تكون في ميزان
حسناتك الملك ولي عهد وكافه الشعب السعودي
شكرا لك يا عم الحمد لله على السلامه يعني
كما رايتم هذا اول شخص يصل او يه من او
ينزل من علامات سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع
كما شاهدتم حديثه ومشاعره الجياشه وكافه
التسهيلات والخدمات التي قدمت لها كما
نشاهد امامكم الان هؤلاء القوات التي تعمل
على تامين وصول الرعايه بمختلف جنسياتهم
من البر في بورتسودان وصولا الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه قوات خاصه مجهزه مؤهله
للتعامل والحفاظ على سلامه وصحه كافه
الرعايه التي عملت عليهم التي عملت على
اجلائهم الحكومه السعوديه ممثله بوزاره
الخارجيه والسفاره السعوديه وكذلك القوات
البحريه السعوديه كما نشاهد الان يتم
التعامل بدءا مع كبار السن وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه نظرا لظروفهم الصحيه
كما اكدنا قبل قليل يتم مراعاه الظروف
الصحيه والنفسيه والع كذلك لكافه الرعايه
من هم علامات سفينه جلاله الملك
ينبع نؤكد انه يتم التعامل معهم بكل يسر
وسهوله وسلامه والتعامل نشاهد اليوم كافه
القوات الامنيه متواجده للتعامل مع هذه
الحالات والتاكد من سلامتهم والتيسير
عليهم حتى يصلوا الى بلدانهم او مقرات
سكنهم في مدينه
جده في الجهه المقابله كما نشاهد الحافلات
تم وصولها
وتجهيزها حتى يستطيع
الرعايه فور نزولهم انهاء اجراءات سفرهم
من قبل جهات المعنيه هنا على ارض الميناء
ومن ثم ركوب هذه الحافلات
وسوف يتم نقله الى مقرات سكنهم للاستراحه
ومن ثم انهاج راس سفر الى الخارج كما
نشاهد ان يتم استقبالهم بالورود وبالحلوى
وبالعبارات الترحيبيه حتى يتم التخفيف على
نفسيتهم وعلى معاناتهم الكبيره جد الذين
عاشوها في الخرطوم خلال الايام الماضيه
نعم كما هو المشهد امامكم الان هذه السيده
[تصفيق]
خالد
نتعرف عليك
نعم كما شاهدتم الان يتم التعامل من قبل
القوات البحريه مع كبار السن ومن ثم بعد
ذلك سوف يقوم باتصال تقوم بعمليه الانزال
بشكل تدريجي من الاكبر عمرا الى الاصغر
عمرا حتى يتم استقبالهم والتاكد من
سلامتهم الصحيه من قبل الاطباء والممرضين
والكوادر الفنيه والطبيه الموجوده ومن ثم
سوف يقومون بركوب هذه الحافلات التي قمنا
باظهارها قبل قليل الوصول الى مقرات سكنهم
في جده وهي عباره عن اربعه فنادق ضخمه
وكبيره تستوعب هذه الاعداد الضخمه كما
ذكرنا في وقت السابق والمتوقع خلال ظرف
الساعه ونصف الى ساعتين سوف يتم انهاء
كافه اجراءات السفر والاتهاء من عمليات
تنقلهم وتنقلهم وصولا الى مقرات السكن في
جده
[موسيقى]
اذا تابعنا مع زميلنا سلطان السلمي نزول
اول شخصين من الرعايه الذين كانوا موجودين
على متن سفينه جلد جلاله الملك ينبع والتي
وصلت الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه تقريبا
ساعتين حتى ينزل كل الرعايه المتواجدين
على متن هذه السفينه هناك تسهيلات كبيره
قدمت لهم حتى وصولهم الى جده عبر بورت
السودان طبعا الرحله كانت حفيفه بالمصاعب
والمخاطر من الخرطوم للوصول الى بورسودان
ومازلنا نتابع طبعا تباعا الناس تخرج من
علامتنا السفينه وتنزل طبعا الى الباحه
المتواجده الى جانب هذه السفينه لاحظنا
هناك فئات عمريه متعدده اطفال نساء رجال
كبار في السن
متواجدين على هذه السفينه حيث هناك اكثر
من 12 جنسيه
تم الحديث عن 12 جنسيه او 14 جنسيه ولكن
نعود نذكر بان هذه السفينه هي الخامسه
التي
ساهمت باجلاء السودانيين الى جده
ومن ثم طبعا بعد ان امنت لهم السعوديه
الاقامه حتى يستطيعوا انهاء اوراقهم
للمغادره الى بلدانهم العديد من الجنسيات
متواجده على متن هذه السفينه وما زلنا
نتابع تباعا نزول الرعايه من هذه السفينه
ونعود ونذكر مشاهدينا بان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه بلينكن كان اعلن عن الهدنه بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه ودعم السريع كان رحب بهذه
الخطوه بالاضافه
طبعا لتمنيات من
الامريكيين ان يلتزم
طرفا النزاع بهذه الهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار
بشكل فوري
ايضا القوى الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
بالسودان رحبت بهذه الهدنه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع اذا هذه اخبار ايجابيه
للسودانيين بان هناك هدنه لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه نامل طبعا ان يتم الالتزام
بها حتى تنتهي عمليات الاجلاء وحتى ايضا
يستطيع
السودانيون ان يتنفسوا الصعداء بعد تسعه
ايام قاسيه من هذا الاشتباك المسلحه
ونتابع مشاهدينا ايضا ما اكدته الخارجيه
المصريه عن مقتل مساعد الملحق الاداري
المصري بسفارتها في الخرطوم معلنه ان
بعثتها في الخرطوم ستواصل عملها وتحمل
مسؤوليتها باجلاء مواطنيها كما ذكرت مصادر
للعربيه ان هناك تنسيقا مع الجانب
السوداني لفتح تحقيق في مقتل احد اعضاء
السفاره المصريه بعد ان طالبت القاهره
مزيدا من التوضيحات حول طبعا ملابسات هذا
الحادث مصادر العربيه ايضا قالت انه سيتم
نقل جثمان عضو مساعد الملحق الاداري على
احدى الطائرات المصريه لنقله الى مصر
لدفنه هناك ووفقا للمصادر فقد تم تشديد
الاجراءات الامنيه حول السفاره المصريه
بالتنسيق بين الجانبين لتامين عناصر
واعضاء السفاره المصريه والتحركاتها خلال
الساعات المقبله بشكل اكبر
وما زلنا مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور لقاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه حيث وصلت سفينه جلاله
الملك ينبع والتي تحمل على متنها تقريبا
199 شخصا بينهم عشره سعوديين واربعه
ليبيين والبقيه من
جنسيات مختلفه من لبنان من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ايضا من تنزانيا من
ليبيا كما ذكرنا ايضا هناك من تركيا من
العراق من هولندا السويد المملكه المتحده
ايطاليا قطر وسوريا
العديد من الجنسيات متواجده على متن هذه
السفينه وكنا تابعنا ايضا كيفيه المساعده
بشكل كبير وخاصه لكبار السن الذين
يتواجدون على متن هذه السفينه الهيئات
الصحيه كما ذكر طبعا مراسل سلطان السلمي
زميلنا قال بانه الهيئات الصحيه ايضا
متاهبه ان كان هناك اي عارض صحي لاحد
الاشخاص ولكنه اكد لنا ان نلاقي اصابات
موجوده على متن هذه السفينه ولكن الهيئات
الصحيه متواجده نظرا لاي شخص من الممكن ان
يكون تعب من هذه الرحله اللي كانت محفوفه
بالمصاعب من الخرطوم وصولا الى بورتسودان
ومن ثم تقريبا عشر ساعات للوصول الى جده
ايضا باستقبال الرعايه هناك
متواجد طبعا مسؤولين
بعتاه الدبلوماسيه قناصل متواجدين على
الارض الى جانب السفينه لا ادري اذا كان
سلطان جاهزا معنا
سلطان
نعم كما تشاهدون تمت نعم تمت عمليات
الانزال من علامته السفينه جلاله الملك
ينبع والان سناخذكم في جوله على احدى
الحافلات التي تم تخصيصها او تخصيصها لنقل
الرعايه الى مقرات السكني نشاهد عدد كبير
من الحافلات
الحديثه التي سوف تقوم بعمليات نقل
الرعايه فور نزوله مباشره من من علامتنا
السفينه الى مقرات السكن وقبل ذلك يتم
انهاء اجراءاتهم بشكل سريع جدا من قبل
القطاعات الامنيه الاخرى الخاصه بانهاء
اجراءات السفر والتاكد من سلامه الحقائب
وغيرها الان ناخذكم في هذه الحافله بشكل
سريع جدا لنشاهد
معكم هذه الصور
نعم كما نشاهد الان بدا هذه الحافله
بالامتلاء بالركاب والرعايه استعدادا
لعمليه نقلهم الى مقرات سكنهم في جده تم
تخصيص اربعه فنادق خاصه جميعها فقط خصصت
لي الرعايه القادمين من السودان وتحديدا
من بورت سودان الذين تم اجلائهم او يتم
اجلائهم من قبل القوات البحريه
السعوديه لا تزال الاعداد تقوم او تتوافد
بالنزول الى ارض قاعده
البحريه قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه الان
نشاهد الاطفال
يقومون بركوب هذه الحافله استعدادا
لتقالهم الى مقرات السكنهم كما نشاهد الان
جنسيات مختلفه اعمار مختلفه عائلات اطفال
وكبار سن وحتى كذلك من ذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه يتم مراعاه كل ذلك هنالك ايضا
موظفين اداريين يقومون بعمليات التوزيع
بين الحافلات حتى تكون كل جاليه مع بعضها
البعض في حافله واحده وفي مقر السكن واحد
نعلم انه الاغلب يكونوا من يعني يكونوا
عائلات واقارب لذلك سوف يعني من الافضل
يكونوا في فندق واحد حتى يستطيع الارتياح
بشكل والشعور بالراحه بشكل كبير جدا
الملته للاطفال يقومون باللهو واللعب بشكل
كبير جدا اثناء وصولهم الى قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه كما نشاهد الان امامكم
الاطفال يشعرون بفرحه مختلفه ودائما فرحه
الاطفال هي مختلفه بطبيعه الحال واكثر
صدقا دائما كما نشاهد هذا الطفل الان
يا حبيبي ههه
يقوم بتقبيل العالم السعودي شكرا لك شكرا
كما نشاهد الان بداوا العائلات يلتقون
برعاياهم بداوا الدبلوماسيين الاجانب
بالتقاب رعاياهم للاستماع اليهم وانا
اجراءاتهم وتسهيل مهمه وصولهم الى بلدانهم
بعد الذهاب الى مقرات السكن
وانهاء كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه الان تتم
عمليات الانزال بشكل تدريجي بدا بكبار
السن وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه والنساء
والاطفال ومن ثم اخيرا تتم عمليه انزال
الرجال في اخر عمليات الانزال نظرا
لظروفهم الخاصه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه لوصول سفينه
جلاله الملك ينبع هذه التغطيه مستمره على
شاشه العربيه مع هذه الصور ولكن ننتقل
الان الى زميلنا طاهر بركه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات